practiquemos un poco y pensemos en cómo
se forman normalmente los iones como
forman compuestos y como nombramos a
esos compuestos entonces empecemos con
un elemento del grupo 1 en esta columna
a los elementos de esta columna se les
conoce como metales alcalinos entonces
empecemos con el potasio que es el
símbolo para el potasio ahora para los
elementos del grupo 1 debemos tomar en
cuenta que su capa externa sólo tiene un
electrón no les importa perder ese
electrón entonces cuando se ioniza
pierden ese electrón y se convierten en
un cateo unión positivo entonces veamos
una situación en la que tenemos potasio
como unión y podemos escribirlo así como
ya vimos en otros vídeos
este es nuestro ión potasio o también
podemos decir que es nuestro potasio uno
más o que es nuestra ocasión de potasio
y ahora vamos al otro lado de la tabla
periódica ahí tenemos a los elementos
que adoran ganar electrones por ejemplo
los elementos en el grupo de los
halogenuros que son los que tenemos en
esta columna estos son los halogenuros y
todos estos elementos tienen 7
electrones en su última capa de
electrónica y desean tener 8 así que son
muy buenos para ganar electrones
entonces supongamos que estamos
trabajando con cloro y el cloro se puede
yo nizar puede ganar un electrón
entonces cuando el cloro gana un
electrón se convierte en un guión
cargado negativamente que lo podemos
escribir como 1 - pero la forma en la
que generalmente nos referimos a una
unión es decir a un ión cargado
negativamente es que en lugar de decir
que este es el avión de cloro podemos
llamarlo cloruro entonces podemos
referirnos a este ión como el ión cloro
ahora como pueden imaginar si el potasio
tiene una carga 1 positiva o simplemente
podemos decir una carga uno más y este
tiene una carga 1 negativa se sentirán
atraídos entre ellos y podrán formar un
compuesto iónico y el compuesto iónico
que formarán lo podemos escribir como
bueno primero escribimos el guión
positivo y después escribimos el guión
negativo entonces este compuesto es el
cloruro de potasio vamos a escribirlo
cloruro
de potasio ahora tal vez me diga bueno
este es una unión porque en lugar de
escribir cloro que es el nombre de este
elemento escribimos la terminación puro
entonces este es una unión y yo sé que
este es el año de cloro cloruro porque
no hicimos algo parecido con el potasio
bueno lo que se acostumbra es que si
alguien dice cloruro de potasio sabemos
que se trata de un compuesto iónico y si
el cloro tiene una carga negativa en un
compuesto iónico todo será neutro
entonces aquí tenemos 1 - y sabemos que
aquí tenemos uno más así que ya sabemos
que estamos trabajando con un cat ión de
potasio y unión cloruro o unión de cloro
podemos referirnos a esto de diferentes
formas pero finalmente este es el
cloruro de potasio
tenemos un potasio cargado positivamente
y un cloro cargado negativamente al que
conocemos como cloruro
en los siguientes vídeos haremos más
ejemplos sobre esto y haremos algunos un
poco más complicados